-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Sandra Oh.
-We were just
talking about Andy.
-We were talking about Andy.
When people say,
"What do you talk about
during the commercial breaks?"
We were genuinely just
sitting here
talking about Andy Samberg.
And why he's a bad guy,
about my dog.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking about things for a
person to be emotional about,
you have finished shooting
the final season
of "Killing Eve."
-Yes!
-Congratulations!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It just started airing.
-Yeah!
-So, yeah.
-I would imagine,
like a lot of shows
that had to do this during
a tricky time,
shooting a final season
in the middle of COVID
must have tempered a little bit
how you can be celebratory.
-True, and also it
really, really limits
how much you can travel.
The show is
a very international show.
And it still remains that,
but this year, during COVID,
you know, like many other shows,
you couldn't really travel.
We couldn't really
travel that much.
So even though we have
exotic locations,
it's exotic locations.
-Like, exteriors.
-Yeah, yeah.
-A lot of "exotic locations"
in the UK.
-Yeah.
-Did you have any sense when you
started making the show --
I know you'd worked on it
for awhile before it started --
that it was gonna be a hit
like this?
Because it was
a very unique show.
Very singular,
when it first came out.
-I think you can never tell.
-Yeah.
-You know,
but the timing was right.
The timing was right,
and one of the things
I'm so proud of
is the unique voice of it,
and the fact that it
completely focuses on women.
And complex female characters.
And I think our show
just hit at the right time.
The genre of it,
the humor of it.
I feel like my and Jodie's
chemistry
is really, really great.
So it was really emotional
and very challenging
to film the finale,
but it's out there now.
-The show is so well-written,
but it's hard to imagine it
with a different cast.
What was it like
seeing those words being read
by you, Jodie, Fiona, the other
people involved in the show
the first time you sat down
at a table read?
-You must know it, right?
It's like, when you do
a table read, right,
which you've done
a bajillion times,
it's the crackle.
-Yeah.
-It's that crackle,
and you can feel.
It's a mysterious thing,
but it happens a lot in theater,
when everyone in the room
can feel like,
"Oh, it's happening.
It's happening."
And not only that,
the next steps,
you're gonna have
with great actors.
You're gonna put that on set,
on film.
I mean, for me, I remember,
like,
particularly Fiona Shaw,
who plays Carolyn,
I completely, utterly fangirled
out when I first met her.
I don't know if you know,
but she is a remarkable
theater actress.
She's a very, very well-known,
very well-regarded
theater actress.
And I saw her in "Medea,"
on Broadway in 2003.
Right? I don't know
if you know the play...
-That's the real deal.
-Right? The real deal.
So when I met her, I did
the very, very last moment.
I'm like, come on.
It's like, "Hi, Fiona.
I saw you in 'Medea.'
This was your last moment."
And acted it out for her.
-People love that.
-Right? [ Laughs ]
But we're friends now.
-Okay, good. It worked out.
I have one more thing
to ask you about.
So you have a new film
coming out,
which seems like, very different
than Disney Pixar.
-Yes, also a mother-daughter
relationship.
-This is "Umma."
-Yes.
-This looks terrifying.
-[ Laughing ]
It is,
it's a psychological horror
that is also based on
a complex relationship
between a mother and a daughter.
-It's a rich vein,
those relationships.
-It is.
I do really like playing it,
you know, again.
It's two young, female,
actually Asian American
filmmakers,
who are like,
exploring stories about mother.
You know,
it's the primary storytelling.
-That's great.
Hey, it is always just
such a delight to see you.
Thank you so much for being here
in person.
-Thank you.
-You guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's Sandra Oh.
"Turning Red" is streaming this
Friday on Disney Plus.